what's up everyone yeah worked its
fortnight Thursday and we fixed the
buttons on our switcher ah it's a good
feeling but yeah we're here
fortnight season 5 is live and we're
about to try to do some of these new
challenges yeah and we'll check out some
of the new areas on the map so no new
map which I didn't expect to get a new
map so what they've done is they've
added like was it like lazy links which
is like took over for Anarchy pills or
whatever oh and then there's like a
whole new desert II area down in the
bottom right if I had that right there's
like this new Viking you're like new
areas yeah I went straight to the game
because I know that's whatever yes
exactly
so we're excited just to show you this
is like if you bought the battle pass or
I think you could can you you have to
buy the battle path through the big guy
so then this is some of the stuff you
can earn for the dude I really want the
is it the kitsune man that looks cool
and then there's also the road trip
which is kind of like the blockbuster
challenges from last year Hellfire gamer
hello and you're spam but if you finish
the challenges you'll essentially get
the Ragnarok guy which i think is at the
very end here let me show you that
that's pretty cool did you know that
actually Michaels through all six things
yes so I actually think that he's just
forgetting to the end of the battle
paths I think this other character is
just someone they haven't oh really okay
maybe like the armor that he accrues
else okay but well you know I need that
anyways I need that Ragnarok skin it's
really um so yeah this could be
something completely different I think
Ben might be onto something there but
we're gonna look at the week 1
challenges maybe nope can't do it from
here
there you go so it's interesting they
from what I can tell they segmented
these yeah it used to be like all of
them were part of the battle pass maybe
now like some of the people that um have
it just like without the battle pass
we'll get a couple challenges for you to
finish and so you know there's these
three and then the battle past ones are
I guess you know search chests not be
Shores search for floating lightning
bolts we've got a bunch of stuff on
gamespot comm with guides of like you
know where these lightning bolts are if
you're looking for that the treasure map
found in risky reels we also have a spot
for that for
or the actual like item is hi Jeremiah
TV Thank You Hye Kyong
let me ponents in retail ro I'm a if you
oh he's in we got it's our boy it's our
boy Nick margarita a former GameSpot I
I'm gonna try to see if he let's do this
the ghost of fortnight pass so well
we're gonna do some duo's with him I
guess see how that goes also because
play a match with a friend is a daily
channel get that as well and then we'll
leave him behind and do our own thing
thank you sorry Nick you might be
watching this you might not be so yeah
this is kind of like that desert II
theme if I could play the intro for you
guys again I would but I can't
but yeah the item shop also looks like
it's expanded it used to be only two
yeah you know we got three shots three
slots for you know if you want to spend
them v bucks
that looks cool I like this Ventura in
and Ventura outfit but I've never
dropped money here I just don't really
care for it too much myself but small
world cup stuff here you know what I've
realized before there used to be just
one dab emote now they're like 7i Rex hi
hi to everyone hello everyone
thanks for tuning in again SWAT live
with me and Ben yeah you know we're live
every day at 11:30 if you haven't hit
that sub button you should so that you
get informed as to when we go live and
or also when we you know put up our
reviews put up our features our previews
all that fun stuff hi can you get Nick
audio probably can't I also try to do my
hair like this guy but it's not blonde
and I also was like oh maybe I can get a
mask and I don't think anyone in the
house flowin yeah exactly you know what
Nick is Nick is really he's not right oh
wait no her match what he's he's not yet
come on Nick I'm about to unready and
leave you here in a second you're
holding up the shame you look at
tumbleweed that's how I feel right now
is that what we had I'm the tumbleweed
getting blown around by the wind no
control Nick please watch me a DMM just
a cinema text hey yo thanks for subbing
thank you appreciate it
thanks to everyone that's either subtour
or thought about subbing we appreciate
it
I'm gonna try to message Nick margarita
here maybe we can call him oh they're
gonna friend phone a friend I like it
that way crime can hear his voice
because I didn't actually think about
this at all coming into it I will put
him on speaker we kind of didn't predict
that he'd he'd be on I you know what
he's been on lately so you know Oh guys
hear that
full full experience this is full and
call volume come on Nicholas maybe you
just go into the bathroom or something
probably is yo Nicky Mario's hurry up
and ready man you holding the stream up
right now we're trying to get those free
5 5 stars here Oh who's on your account
then oh this guy do you want to play or
not yeah yeah we gotta get that daily
challenge man oh he's ready here we go
also crime says he misses you so that's
why you're on speaker oh he can hear you
alright I'll let you hold on to this
yeah one round I'm gonna let Ben hold on
to the phone now
speaker ghetto F hey man that's not what
you got live production sometimes we
just gotta go live with it that's like
the hitmarker stuff is different too you
see that with the shotgun it shows you
like every yeah yeah there's a lot of
weird UI updates they've done even the
text is different and stuff like that
which is interesting Rory I look at that
as different so is it as a person who
got a victory Royale in 50 be 50 this
morning man look at you totally did all
the work definitely didn't get carried
well how many kills did you have Oh
let's drop it that Viking place Viking
place I dropped a marker that's cool cuz
there's riffs now yeah but they oh he'll
know he sees it he's got it he's got to
see it right let me jump at his bus
screw you bending
Wow guys coming after you Jared cats guy
Jared how can I help you dude
you seem to be really frustating frosty
keep it frosty I think I under shot here
when I am drew under shot oh we can show
the rift though sorry I'm gonna grab
this this thing and then he sees next to
the the camping camping area then I'm
gonna take this rift and then we're
gonna fly up in the sky I'll get up
there when I dang well please here we go
oh yeah I'm coming Nick I'm making a
minute though where they at dude I'm the
man's blind I hear a lot of gunfire this
is part of a challenge what do you say
apparently SMG is very strong now there
you go get that silenced SMG we got the
new meta it's already evolving well you
need SMG kills as part of the challenge
and stuff like that
he's got to have some GTECH though but
you're better killing it
do you have their first aid I need
bandages
I need anything hey max how's it going
hope you're having a good day that's
almost like a bandage I'd rather have
bandages right now Yeah right okay
so good question who's gonna get the
most kills between whom yet we knew and
neck yeah oh what's that
that's a hand cannon it's a jiggle baby
I don't know Nick I don't I don't think
so
Oh ghostly vago how are you getting
that's it
no streamers luck here there's a there's
a challenge for sticky grenades yeah
that's worth picking up
what's he got for me this will bandage
faster right yeah that's how you do it
you use the gravity to to wrap the
bandage quicker crime says you're the
best without him Eric place works Wow I
got five kills last week it's true I was
there for that I am AC Tech we had ace
air-conditioner strats yeah five kills
in one round he tore it up he was it
like to hell that one boy sick wrong
game wait oh wait chicken dinners as in
victory Roy Alice because poke geez not
even on PlayStation that's pretty good
Nick you're coming up in the world you
found out the proper console play on
that I should probably be playing on
instead of this harder console called PC
we're all the real competitions at right
dang way are we in the circle oh we're
okay everyone knows the competition's
really on mobile okay no no no I can't I
can't I can't I have 50 already hey mega
light how you doing welcome YouTube
official it's already out my dude it's
been out for a while I just out for a
while you got this just go search it up
in the store and get your fortnight on
the go on probably bandages and stuff
like that or like way more important in
a like team I feel like team
duos are like you know oh it's rip oh
look I'm in the sky oh you found a rift
oh wait there's two layers of it now
dang everything's broken it's
interesting should record that don't
mind me you guys and video record here
boom lacked it a little bit spicy
alright whatever oh dude the riffs condo
that's kind of there no no the second
one all right whatever we gotta go yeah
crazy this guy's crazy man
this guy's crazy it's a real wild card I
think he wants to launch pad oh I like
this there's no damage okay there's no
damage off bouncies oh yeah it should
work yeah that's what the the pro
streamers are doing now they just build
really high and then they use the bounce
pad to like like tricks and stuff like
that see there I don't even know this
good thing I check Pro not really I'm a
pretty amateur nah I haven't even won a
victory Royale you kind of know what
you're doing though I mean I just
my aim is like average yeah at best and
then the problem is I don't do the
building is I'm just not good at the
build i can't build to save my life
exactly and build up someone's in a golf
cart should we got it you gotta take it
back from him Nick we need that golf
cart pick up that golf cart tech it's in
front of us they're driving the Tilted
does he not oh well I obviously he can't
hear me you gotta tell him though he can
he can hear okay yeah okay we're all
here I hear gunfire I hear a lot of good
fire I think they're like on this Ridge
of tilted we could steal their golf cart
maybe hey Jack how are you doing
oh there's a lot of it's getting spicy
over here hated playground mode I think
you're asking word playground mode go
they took it out it was a limited time
mode do words the act yeah he said
playground while he's gone yeah yeah
yeah that's a lightning bolt by the way
right there that thing oh that's pretty
easy to find yeah oh there's a guy right
there I don't have the aim the aim Ben
I'll have the confidence to take the
shots got a crouch and then then all
your shots will hit everything do we
take the shot though
do we alarm him yeah yeah I don't know
we go wherever you want
we already got five Battlestars is how I
look at okay Bob wants to know if Nick
gets to play video games at his new job
oh shoot someone's behind us I think I
think so I saw shots from the hill
there's definitely got in front of us
too
later your laser dim there's another one
there's another one he's dropping down
you got real cheeky oh yo we got him
with a little sticky it's we're at peak
performance things are not gonna get
better than this I say this every stream
I think you're just actually getting
better
I haven't played really since last time
or there's more amateur people on you
know it could just even out the field
oh okay Nick Nick talk to me where they
at Nick oh yeah no he's behind you he's
behind you yeah yeah they're coming from
where we dropped down from I don't want
to engage one guys going way high and
one guys down below oh look at all those
goodies oh he's picking up all the
goodies I don't get cheeky I get it real
cheeky Oh what from downtown
got him I can't believe this this is
fantastic
Nick's down I gotta kill his friend you
gotta save her boy no he's he he's
bleeding out
I'm getting shot right now or it was oh
he stinks oh no stink bomb yeah watch
the deagle Nick don't die on me why are
you crawling in the streets just wants
to get back to his friend one last time
I'll come in Nick oh there's so many
goodies here though but the ultimate
goodie is friendship he stuck you yeah I
stuck his friend though and killed his
friend it's okay I'm committed I'm 100
percent committed I'm committed please
Nick get us out of here I'm sorry Nick I
was committed all right one more I tried
to save him crime I was committed I was
still really around though four kills
there was a med pack - and a gold famis
that I left feels bad man feels bad Joe
I'm still saying those four kills I
guess I didn't know stinkbomb goes
through yeah I think it exists like you
know what I mean like it goes through
the wall
oh good first good first one oh yeah
yeah I cancelled out of it on accident
really well you can do it on PC Nick it
is the same trailer that they they
released for the announcement if it's
any consolation oh it's by on the
interwebs I said a really high bar on
myself yeah I don't know if I could
replicate any of the things you just saw
I think you guys are in top form today
and this is literally yellowed those
grenades and it works what you got them
that's what you like that you know what
sucks though is dumb the stickies don't
count as like a limbs in duo's over the
knockdown yeah yo desert will go desert
somewhere somewhere is this desert
everyone's gonna be there though
I don't either is there all learning
today that's a golf cart track Mario
Kart or that's a go-kart that's a track
that's a track for learning the track
yeah but where's the cart though you'd
think it'd have to be here
I see no carts I see no guns can't
believe there's something there there's
one on the back of the truck right there
down below you like straight down below
is there yeah right there all right
Nick there's a there's a cart oh there's
also a purple right here there's a lot
of good things around this area it's
right here that's me that's me I killed
a guy there's a foul ass up here oh
there's a lot it was all gonna get spicy
Nick spice up your life
I'm coming Nick I'm coming no no don't
leave me I thought there's a shotgun
here I think the back is the better seat
to be in all right the back all right
here we go can I shoot oh yeah let's go
baby
you can stand how come I can't shoot you
should know I think he has a stop for
what can't do it there you go
oh it's a speed thing Oh cart get that
other cart vehicle of vehicle combat we
got it
I got hitmarkers auto right out where
you at Oh little Welbeck think I got
left behind I'm running out of ammo not
gonna lie oh I hit that guy yeah I see
that I see that I'm trying to shoot
those guys man this is auto Royalle baby
or golf cart Royale cart Royale it's
it's what we've been waiting for
oh there's a guy right there to our
right oh he's getting a lit up when I
hit him can you learn to drive where are
you taking us I don't have enough ammo
to shoot the wall out I have 55 bullets
you want me to waste all my ammo all
right
these next level strats mother in there
now you're in sync
Oh God oh my goodness I got one what
this is so awkward Nick I'm trying I got
my god I got him what Haru oh yeah pick
up their loot I don't know it's it's all
the stream they better never take these
carts out they're the best thing they've
ever added this is great Nick is drunk a
shield shield shield okay there's a
there's a lefty two minis or one mini
thought this was pub guy oh you thought
well oh there's another so close okay
again some some good ammo here
are we taking the cart oh there's a
medkit there's a clinger tell me how
much good stuff oh there's only three
bullets in that that's not so good uh
you take in the mant you want to take
the bandages Oh what was that
there's there's someone shooting yeah we
got to get back in the cart man we're
only Opie in the cart
someone's gonna roll up on you oh boy
cart life
punch it oh why can't I
I don't understand okay yo get rid of my
goodness
Hey Nikki's one guys down oh I hit him
again can I met while oh this popke oh
they I'm netting i'm netting don't oh
god there's so many people get out of
get us out of here
punch it I'm healing I hope I don't know
I mean it's in his name I was like one
second away from from full healing
that's unfortunate hey good golf cart
kills what do you say I'm dead yeah
everyone is your sole aim time is he
like on delay is everything okay I'm
dead new menu I'm so dead I died with
you it says he's playing he's
now he's he's buing the gut Oh yikes
yeah yeah let's do one more one one Oh
stink bomb counts as kills here these
will be easier solo yeah but you get a
limb in stead of like the Knockouts
straight up man
like one second bandage faster it's
interesting though so you get into the
end of the front seat yeah you can't you
can't bandage from the back seat and I
would assume you can't shoot unless
you're in the back seat I feel like the
back seat is just dangerous so your
character gets too scared to do anything
see you out that game logic he's trying
to like grab onto the hood instead of do
anything else or the top of the car
maybe maybe the side seat is the the
better seat I should have the golf cart
man heck yeah Eric plays best with golf
carts and air conditioners what happens
if you combine the two I don't know man
a really cool kind of I kid like so many
kills
I think they can because I was doing
damage to them
spicy
why where we going are we going to the
desert oh we're going to the desert
we're going to the golf cart that's the
blue ones a golf cart I don't care I
don't care what happens we're riding the
golf cart I feel like that that should
be the focus is just getting golf cart
this is the stream not even the
challenges just call cars welcome to go
oh no that's what Nick Oh Nick wants
spicy at lazy links all right
oh the golf the golf golf town yeah do
you get your your golf ball emote Nick
can you can you actually call it a golf
ball so you play go gone right to the
pool oh we're going right to the pool
well it seems like it sure as hell seems
like we're going to the building I came
in too hot I think I might need to find
myself a sand pit oh there's one there
oh there's a golf cart there's tennis
courts no I'm not going to the golf cart
I need a gun you're the driver you're
the wheelman in the group
watch out Nick the other guy has a gun
he's a weak though he's weak he's weak
yes I took way too many shots really we
got the Dooleys though yeah oh we did
get another guy Oh Nick oh no quick Nick
dream you had the revolver yeah I know
all right back back to uh do it again
how do I get the llama you just kind of
gotta get lucky Jose I found it in
back-to-back maps just out a chance but
it's that that's one of those oh you
know how to do it fifty be fifty yeah
probably the easiest way to well do you
think that's the easy way to compete
with everyone else
yeah yeah llamas kind of luck of the
draw I got a kill though yeah I guess I
mean like I felt like I hurt really hurt
the other guy so someone else must have
finished him off or something yeah all
right we need SMG eliminations I really
got to work on some of these challenges
I don't know I see what I gotta see
where the the map puts us Nick oh we're
going we're going to the golf carts the
golf carts every time oh yeah yeah yeah
yeah definitely
oh look at that guy he's got a huge
magnifier glass here's you solving
mysteries hmm because he small ones not
good enough clearly exactly yeah big
mystery to solve you gotta have a big
magnifying glass dang oh you know why
else it could be easier because I'm
playing against console people oh yeah
you do have them kind of brought back
yeah that's the thing
it's gonna be real hard solo later no
it's fine Ben quick go to your desk just
pop in hey look guys Ben's co-hosting
from his desk oh we're going to the golf
course yeah let's do it or the race
course the race track
oh is that like a nice little like motel
building
[Music]
oh this is bad
I'm really wanna make it yeah I'm really
far Nick I'm that you're you're gonna
come in hot I'm gonna have to come to
this motel real quick that's shake I'll
meet you there I'll meet you there
one guns good enough all right I don't
have a long-range weapon oh yeah oh
where we go maybe on the card
where we going how do ice love control I
don't know where are we going all I have
is a shotgun what do you think
no just me pretty sure it's uh nailed it
oh I hear chest her chest too
there's a pistol here we go it's in the
bathroom uh minis minis
this is not a good spot to do this but
whatever it's fine uh Oh a lot of common
guns going on
real common no not into that I think you
might have we got to go next building
this is this is actually feels like pop
G yeah I'm not gonna lie just like going
from spot to spot
yeah like is this looted what look so
the doors are open keep driving
really did you see these things the two
little derp burger and the tomato town
they're actually still in the world oh
no one's here Oh nope so no what the
hell is that
sweet photo they're shooting they're
shooting up there that's for sure it's a
built in the saw building is there a
boost button
I don't know we'll find out later wait
no Nick I'm coming now you're good oh
right in front of us oh yeah I run him
over
what Oh run him over again dude I want I
want to see oh shoot his friends here Oh
No
yeah there you go get us out of here
someone shooting at us bro okay yeah
blue tum mm-hmm I'll be right here
exactly yeah Ludo I'm like dude shot at
bro uh-oh he found that funny oh I only
left a big shield feels bad it's all
right we got we did that it was really
cool watching John wick get punted
whether I don't know if anyone saw it
was like a you hit like a thud I need to
get some SMG kills smg's
I know where this is it doesn't look
like hitting people with the golf cart
does damage it didn't look like it it
looks like it just bounces peeping out
any more updates and they will make it
pub you know hey you know what they're
ready they're ready kind of like that's
that's Rory in the battle royale Jose
gets gets the kill at retail yeah I need
to do that oh um once I finish up with
Nick will really really focus on the
challenge but we're just checking out
the new areas you know like I'm taking
all the sights because it's gonna be
harder for me to get those kills that
you guys are seeing without a driver hey
Nathan how are you doing we're having a
wonderful Thursday I don't think you
can't either
she's got Tokyo drifting I like it Matt
no not yet
so still filling out has he even given
the prompt to start the match or
whatever yet shown the 84 people in here
hey better than the calling yikes we
were gonna actually stream the culling
and then I try to get into some games
and I just never got more than myself
really
and then now apparently as as of today I
think the article was like that like
there's like two people playing or
something he's crashed
oh great soloing solo get salut that's
fine
we'll just make it real spicy and
striking tilted yeah there's like a
lightning bolt here though so that's
good you didn't cover him when he went
for loot I was reloading crime I also
tried to advise him not to get out
because we're getting shot sometimes NYX
awareness of people shooting him out is
like not he doesn't sense it because he
just sees loot in front of them when in
fact the loot is like the perfect bait I
don't I guess you have to build up to
that thing to get the lightning bolt
maybe possibly I don't think you can
just fall on it right Wow no one oh
there's one person don't come here
I'm dropping hella slow this is the
Czar's oh where did you come from John
wick Senor wick what you guys stream
calling no there's no one to play
calling against
wait is he coming back to thee Nick are
you are you on your way back
gotcha oh and even know I had the wings
of Valor did the the calling actually
like trying to release when the colony
happened release on Tuesday though
but even then sketchy I think I wouldn't
I wouldn't have jumped for it yeah so
I'll shoot I can't shoot them show the
map here which is no unfortunate where
is
well this isn't look like him but it's
possible yeah it's 70 they're seven
weeks yeah or seven weeks oh no no not
not the actual Viking at the end of the
the pass rewards oh that's like a
hundred isn't it 100 yes a hundred
trying to get long play that fortnight
there's math in there and I haven't
worried about what he just said sorry
did you get on any of the emotes for uh
for throwing basketballs around or
anything no no it's all right Nick
thanks for tuning just wow I'm so used
to I'm so you said thanks Nick
crime says he loves you and goodbye
all right man bye buh-bye alright that
was playing with Nick margarita for
about half an hour some good stuff there
all right so we're definitely gonna do
some challenges now a hundred percent
try to get some risky or sorry retail
row kills the the hidden treasure map is
where's that little thingy I need your
help I forget exactly where it is right
I totally like I walked by oh it's here
I think it's in this thing
alright well I'll see I'll see if you
can prove that you got it first and then
we'll pull it up if it's not there okay
I think it's here though in this thing
I'm not a hundred percent sure it's
either here or somewhere similar to that
and then we got lightning bolts which
are kind of all over though yeah that's
a multiple drop thing bro alright just
gonna drop fine but it's not the same
when you're by yourself yeah it
definitely it definitely is hello pain
it's definitely more fun when someone's
driving and you're you're able to kind
of shoot it's kind of weird though like
I don't know I would just assume that if
you're in the back and you have a gun
that like your gun with you
but you actually have to pick a gun and
then it shows up oh really like it
didn't like default you just put your
hands there maybe maybe that's like not
intended thing because that seems like
it's not intended you think something or
maybe I'm just crazy and I'm dumb
maybe check and kind of like clarify
that so I'm not gonna go to the actual
treasure map to find the treasure map
but I think that the actual thing you
need to find this week is in that little
area over there where the rocks are
where there probably aren't any guns and
I'm gonna die but you know it's all good
hey you completed a challenge and that's
what matters yeah that's a 10 Battlestar
challenge school's thrown out it's not
there
it isn't sick it's in tomato town it's
in tomato town but okay well this is a
cool I came here for the shotgun alright
then I need your help then if it's not
here then it's on a Ledge facing the
town sweet there's a test I was testing
you thanks school making sure everyone
had it all under control I wanted to
make sure you're going to school we have
something we definitely have something
Chris was working on it Kevin we're two
please add tomato somewhere over there
oh there's a golf cart
oh the chest in here somewhere in order
to find the treasure you gotta head to
the tunnel south of tomato town I'm on
top of northern northern entrance and
you'll find the battle path icon there's
no picture what's up doc what's up
Calvin
I don't think so babe my stream please
maybe after but they're definitely not
gonna do that right now
all right so powerslide is space oh no
this I believe this is the me I'm shot
at that's fine
they can't oh what a golf cart do I
serpentine you think so
yeah I'm a drunk driver you can't hit me
like the physics on the it's pretty slow
I'm not gonna lie that's real good well
I think there's a boost like hit shift
or something I am hitting shift I'm
holding shift so I swear I saw someone
boosting they must have did the power
slide and Mario Kart like disease oh
that's exactly what it is
Oh use me oh shoot
those parts are just Mario Kart cards
did it Oh so Stokes can't drive I'm just
excited about realizing what's happening
that's fantastic
what you know about dead oh my god oh
crap Ben it's fine it's fine
everything's nailed it stuck the landing
no problem oh oh I got off-track for my
challenge where am I supposed to go it's
okay you ended up having fun again you
can drive now yeah Peyton
they put golf carts see me they have
boost so it's you need to go to the
North hamato north of tomato
it says north of tomato town and up the
tunnel of the tunnel south of tomato
town
Oh then climb on top of the northern
entrance that is there the spot on the
map kind of looks like this
emissary wrap just riding up on the wall
that's fine nailed it
so it's like somewhere over here that
looks something up there yeah I think no
I passed it it's the actual here we got
the actual image of it if you're if
you're looking out towards tomato town
it should look like this oh it's I think
it's there just heard about sandbox mode
uh it's it's already gone they got these
limited time modes that just cycle in
and out thing it's a choice yeah can I
get a replay I'm actually salt because I
generally suck at dance corny I was like
oh I know exactly where he's gonna come
from look good it looked good to me
mm-hmm I was there for it I like didn't
even bother shooting because I was like
oh he's gonna be dancing I want to make
sure I line this shot up and they're
like oh no he's not dancing I'm just
dead already too late awesome thank you
thanks game it's okay we had fun
drifting yeah we discovered that the
cars are like Mario karts and now we've
got an exact location on the map that we
can just drop our stuff at okay okay so
it's like it's like here yeah yeah like
just above that area little salty bliss
all right expect that on the stream
expect that uh as we go along here
dude I'm busted up too Peyton I didn't
get a chance to do any playground mode
or a sandbox mode I'm sure we'll be back
I'm sure I'll be back too but it's it's
weird that people keep putting modes and
games and then taking them away no you
know what it is I think at least from
four nice perspective like you know how
they cycle a lot
it's like reasons to come back to the
game that's fair which you know sure it
kind of sucks that like it's not there
all the time but I don't know even goes
back to like that Rainbow six siege when
they had the combi mode exactly
or overwatch overwatch does a lot of
like timed events type thing you know
cuz it generates buzz and oh I don't
know a playground mode necessarily I got
cabbage I don't even know what that
means because the guys name was cabbage
or something who likes cabbage I only
like cabbage on st. Patty's Day there
you go a seasonal treat or or when you
get like like LLS or something oh look
at this guy that's it he's going for the
same thing that guy's gonna smoke us no
we ran away
is it here I know it's down there where
he was so hear something at the dirt
area sup don't you dude don't do it what
okay although it's loading everything's
fine we're all cool here we're so
screwed the wrong way you don't see me
well there's a shotgun there probably
200 cents to you what yeah that's fine I
thought I was gonna close this door and
then go out that door and then the door
and get the shotgun the door closed on
you man what's that regeneration nation
how's it going I oh we got what we
needed there which is good Nick's
playing solo that's good we need to drop
and reap that's where we got go some
retail with some some SMG that would be
the dream and then we gotta find some of
these lightning yeah last region I
bought battle pass on day one and didn't
play until the last week I didn't learn
my lesson I bought season five I'll pass
to this time I'll totally get into it
yeah I mean the good news is you can
always like as you rack up challenges
you end up probably doing some of them
on accident if you don't do them each
week right yeah but it is easier a week
to week to finish some of them just so
that you kind of get them out of the way
I'm kind of like like I bought the
battle pass for last season and I I
played maybe like five games and I felt
real bad about it you played five oh
because you only play five here yeah but
I think I'm more interested in this one
just because of the Mario Kart golf
carts and they might actually play a bit
more
sound oh I wonder you can probably have
two people gunning from the back right
you have to be able to you maybe
possibly retail what I'm really hoping
is they put in in like a proper racing
mode oh okay so you're you're asking for
like Sparrow racing lease I mean the
mechanics are there it's building up I
can see it at some point smoking is bad
kids yeah did I agree smoking is bad
it's weird that more and more people are
just like coming into like self-promote
yeah I don't know I guess it's like
doesn't matter I just find it funny yeah
oh there's no chest on top of any tips
for a noob I only like four eliminations
anymore I feel like we're starting you
probably don't want to go to some of
these spicier areas I mean even though
it is yeah you open it okay you got the
gun
you got everything what the hell she's
very quick at pressing the e button
dare you chase chase him down yeah I
stole my kill dang oh that guy why did
he just die everyone's coming in oh my
lord then I got the worst nope he's gone
I am so bad just retire me I got my kill
stolen I couldn't kill a jumping guy
like sure you're you're trying to be
taxable
you being a professional you know yeah
that's that's what it was you were just
pacing your shots you knew you didn't
need to kill him cuz he's gonna come
back around I don't I'm gonna struggle
getting kills I need every kill I can
get been fair how's it going converse
saying yo back at it again gotta say the
season battle pass seems not good to me
this time around really uh I feel like
this one's this one's more more to what
I'm into I guess it's crazy weird
I kind of fell off in the superhero
business but hey that's what's great
about all of it though certain people
like certain things oh do it mean you
you try for the no I hit him once he's
really weak oh no it's my fault
I had two chances for kills and I wasted
it get that lightning bolt in there if I
could have I would have I didn't
headshot that guy hit on 490 Rene's at
you I don't care if he's doing grenades
it was even the peak again and he didn't
peek yeah yeah I know it's a challenge
school but I don't know how he's gonna
get to it without getting shot to hell I
was trying to get my retail kills we're
trying to get those those kills you know
we just got one of the things where we
gotta find stuff now we're all training
off to finding one for four just doing
some some murdering it's good to have a
balance
or not no balance
way to try us after work
hey man it's gonna be a good time all
the people signing on man dusty did it
filled out yeah it's it's almost back to
like a normal-looking area I think
there's like you have the map up right
oh I don't know if we have them oh we
have the lights or one well yeah we have
the lightning bolt on another one then
let's go back and find that then heard
that one for there's I think there's a
lightning bolt in Griese there you know
we're dumb now for Tilted I'm gonna try
to head over to retail see if anyone
wants to battle again oh shoot
what's up season five added motion
controls for the switch version - god I
can't play hi hey motion controls I like
it it's it's um some good business
what's up zesty how you doing
you need Nick
like general zod needs Superman yeah
yeah I'll show you crime oh we've got a
whole map just with everything laid out
do you think I can pick this lightning
bolt while I'm flying through it maybe I
don't fit like a touch it kind of thing
oh no it's a graphic kind of thing no
pretty much no the problem is I have my
account tied to my PlayStation account
so I can then PC no thanks n ps4 so
unless I want to have like separate
progress or buy a second battle pass I
can't play it on my switch
got a common pistol there that's a gun
getting shot from multiple dimensions I
could have killed that one guy if that
other guy wasn't shooting yeah dang it
where your thoughts on the season so
this season so far I like the go-kart
the golf carts the golf carts are very
good addition I haven't ran around this
area enough but it's always good to have
changes in the onto the map so you know
hopefully more points of interest I
haven't had enough time to practice my
short game at the putt putt at the lazy
links I don't know I think I kind of
wish there was more stuff to the map
yeah I think this is kind of what you
should expect is par for the course for
each season now I'm the only bet more
stuff is gonna happen as the season goes
on though because they've been doing
that like constantly changing and
shifting business
we've still got rifts open in the sky I
feel like more stuff can fall in and
part of me was hoping that like the
rifts would take you somewhere else but
they just drop you from the sky yeah
you know I like the look of the season
yeah I really want that mask this is a
new area that boat the biking area down
there we went there earlier
we've bond the Paradis while I'm
dropping retail I'm trying to get this
challenge done do that thing it's
snowing he had so many chances
oh that's someone's effect there were
snow flakes there I saw what you saw
maybe it was coming from that crack that
crack giant the giant Chris no crack
apparently a day is a I've learned today
is a like slang for cocaine not
necessarily yay day but yeah by itself
yay
really yeah I did not know that I listen
to a lot of hip-hop in middle school
maybe it's cuz I said yeah and then day
maybe Jordan de Freitas say do you love
me and I'm not I don't get the second
part of that so I'm not gonna say it I
don't know it depends how nice for you
to me
please please be nice yeah please
big shield [ __ ] got shotgun shields no
matter where you're going 39 for a
headshot 25 please hello yakeru nice
thank you shotgun I guess I'm still
happy but that's a that's a kill yeah
you know we should have been done with
the challenge right now I heard they
kind of nerf this shotgun swap thing
yeah I saw like a ton of people on
Twitter last night who just screenshot
that part of the patch notes and SMG
damage is a thing so AG the great says
that skin is lit yeah you get it fro
well not free but if you buy the battle
pass you get this schism and then you
can modify it to with doing challenges
which is free pretty sweet I want that
mask one
yeah the max likes for the third tier
challenge you'd also get like jackets or
capes and stuff it's it's wild oh hello
that's another one another one we're
really weak though the gaming box how
are you doing we need a health somewhere
anywhere
streamers like streamers look we need a
med pack or bandages
sort of fun sound to hear at all none of
those are fun sounds to hear there it is
Oh your footstep no wait help hate it
you got what you wanted I got faded ah I
was I took see you know what happened I
was like I'm badging now's the time to
kind of like you thought everything nice
and safe stretch it out I collect those
rewards I could have got the s mmm-hmm
Oh V bucks
sweet v bucks gotta have V bucks so how
are we doing we need one more in retail
we pretty good we got two there should
have if I didn't choke the shotgun kills
earlier we begin we got to do some
chests and snobby good everything's
coming along gotta close the distance
when you got that shot it yeah I know I
mean I'm trying the gaming box what's up
y'all get close but you can't get too
close
missing every shot
so I didn't realize it so I picked up
back when save the world was like the
only mode in the game I like got like a
like one of the more expensive packs for
it and I forgot that I had it until
someone was like talking about how
they've basically funded all their
battle pass purchases with all the free
v bucks you get from playing save the
world really so I didn't realize that I
could probably just fund like playing
battle royale just by playing the
single-player but that means I'd have to
play the single-player and you kind of
already like don't play that much or
watch it as much anymore
I sold my soul for V bucks dab was uh
was a good dramatic reading there
what are they updating save the world
mode I have no idea I have no they
usually do I love me some time gun Tommy
was actually pretty fun I liked the
sound effect on it too it's weird that
it's classified as an SMG though but
sure yeah it's a weird choice but how is
he so much farther ahead of me yeah I
always am convinced that there's just
some sort of weird science to following
that I don't understand because people
are always underneath me alright I was
like no one's gonna go to retail right
we're so far from it no everyone wants
their challenge yeah chill it this house
[ __ ] oh there's a guy at that house
and you just got a shield I don't know
if I want to squabble with him but you
might get a shield that's Larry's
clothes it's pretty pretty alright
something to get some free potshots in
there but not the case hello
actually we've gotten a mess around with
a tommy gun much but I from what I've
seen other people do with that it seems
pretty cool
I I wish the dual pistols shot faster
instead of being like they hurt though
if you hit with both it's like 40 damage
each I think yeah yeah but when I when I
see like dual pistols I don't think like
oh yeah yeah there's I think they're
gonna be like fast shoot a me spam yeah
but I'm gonna do it either way you look
cool try to find some people get a get a
cool murder going I get a good Oh
someone in someone built up do we dare
grab that lightning bolt is it worth
they're standing still that was an odd
choice I'll take it we're good yeah try
going up there now I mean yeah you have
nothing to lose you got your mommy's
yeah
there we go the editor purple pump
shotgun yet I don't think so the hunting
the oh the the hunting the long range
shotgun there's a purple version of that
oh really
you guys are dope thank you for giving
me something to watch while I eat wrong
you make dubstep hey man keep doing the
thing I'm glad you're having a good time
double shotgun is officially dead says
converse heavy shotgun is the new king
downtown whoo oh they actually made it
that's a good toss check it the Crouch
the Cubs tag improved accuracy downtown
it's gonna see him pop up in the air I
almost never even pick up those guns
because there's no chance I'll ever hit
anything with it
yeah hey Dustin how are you yeah
whatever hope you're having a good
thurzo I just took massive fall damage
whoops it's fine massive damage health
as a crutch you don't need it especially
when you've got a light machine gun
I'm still thinking back to that time
you're playing with nicking you know
that like machine-gun golf cart combo
and I was too good that was very silly
actually I think we got to go all right
let's see if I remember I do this that's
pretty good
sure watch me get killed by that guy
that I was trying to snipe for the like
longest time Jefferies s whatever
happened on the crossbow that's a good
question did they take it out I I guess
I haven't seen it
mooshrooms perfect pump shotgun don't
know if I should get fortnight a gaming
box if you're curious about it you can
you can try the free-to-play version at
least
yeah Battle Royale and if you like the
Battle Royale you can put as much money
into it as you'd like to which is nice
but yeah give it a download and see if
you enjoy it
get your friends downloaded because it's
free tis free and consoles in cosplay
yes true
yea save the world it costs the monies
but that's that's just the like story
mode thing that no one please you know
that I mean there's gotta be people
still playing it right I was searching
around videos one night I was bored and
I found a set of videos for fortnight's
save the world that are based around
people who scam other people for like
but high-quality guns you can scam so
like the the thing is you you craft like
high quality weapons in the game and
they're very hard to come by
and apparently people will go into
lobbies and they'll build like trading
chambers where like one person stands at
one end and the other person stands at
the other end and someone has to mediate
and they build walls and like make
things that you can throw the guns over
so you can't steal them back so like the
people will go in and they they're like
oh I don't know this guy but he's
totally like his friend and they they
pretend to mediate and then they both
grab the gun and they're they just leave
but apparently it's it's a real issue it
sounds a pretty shitty yeah don't don't
steal things from people wrap this whole
thing breaks I think it does maybe
possibly I probably could edit this
hello hello yeah I wish that Xbox people
in PlayStation people could play
together - I it's a thing that I'm very
strong opinion I really wish that Sony
would just with my life
just let it let people play with other
people but I understand what they're
doing they've got a lot of market share
and they've got a lot of bad bad did you
guys know I said she said you know what
the trick is just don't look at the
health bar and keep running instead it's
totally fine sweet 360 see you're
styling on it I guess I might have been
able to make it if I did 360 no you're
fine it's fine
no just don't look at the health cover
cover up the health of that bottle just
now I would have made it been spending
360 everything's gonna be fine
everything's gonna be fine it's okay I
would have made it if I didn't I really
think I would have made it if I didn't
360 it would have been very close even
you got the basketball how do I use that
so it's a it's an emo and apparently you
can use it to like shoot shoot hoops can
be cool he has a jumping pad yeah I
guess I could've did that too I panicked
man I panicked
it's okay I know it's too late for you
guys to help me that's all right
good old delay but she went out in style
though and that's that's kind of I guess
so I did the random yeah
all right can you pull up that lightning
bolt again got the map right there oh
yes you won't try that basketball you
know a chance to do it yeah that's a
huge basketball make sure everyone can
see it up you run over and grab it again
but we could retry later Oh after I
killed someone how I do that wailing
woods up at the top there's near tomato
right or in the water I jump it oh crap
but if I have to build to it I'm not
gonna have mats for it mmm so I just
grab a tree or sir actually one there I
don't see it it's oh there it is
literally where my thing is oh you yeah
just do exactly where to go yeah we're
gonna have to go to tomato
rest in peace that big tomato head thing
that it might be somewhere though cuz I
heard the derp burger is it a near
Pleasant
well that guy's clearly going for the
challenge yeah definitely
just grab a gun and make your way over
any mats oh hello face off excuse me
face on face off
I'm very excited for for what's happens
one of my favorite movies actually
haven't watched it in a long time though
house haven't washed it in a while
I want to make sure we have enough mats
which nothing would hurt me more than to
not have enough mats going to it I might
not even have enough I can only build a
lot for high that's maybe I don't know
Ben I should have built from here huh
maybe wait a minute
nailed it oh oh not like this oh my god
it's right right there
I'll be back for you it was so close
I could sense it I sensed a disturbance
in the force you're looking really cool
though with those uh dual pistols so
thanks I think the gifting system will
come I feel like eventually a gifting
system would probably make sense so I
got to build your way back up oh wait I
had 20 more brick dad maybe and you
didn't get brick from that tree I'll
tell you that much everything's
everything's a-okay
we're gonna get this lightning bolt I'd
laugh if I just got sniped right now
hello
someone is trying to take a shot there
you go don't do it I'm not worth it
crime says remember when I said get
double guns and vehicles in fortnight
we're like nah now it's real it's crimes
crimes predict in the future I don't
recall this Hey excuse me
CID the random kid I'm just gonna assume
he was a low-health because that was
very clean could be like 81
was that Tommy got a grenade
we got spot for it where they at though
been there gotta be somewhere around
here
I think everyone split off from trying
to get the the token up there we're in
the circle this time good
I think anyone's gone in there I doubt
it
oh you mean like yeah someone's gone in
there already supposedly was there like
an actual goodbye thing up here no oh
there is see Oh
rest in peace
tomato guy tang the mayor of tomato town
taken from us too soon too soon too
yellow
normally I would say don't break the
trees down but I don't think anyone's
here anymore
I think they see me it is what it is I
think everyone might be gone uh foreign
I got a new map not necessarily a new
map it's a map update there's there's
new places you can go
they added golf carts which control like
Mario karts and your boys very excited
about it yes yes sir it's definitely
more fun with a group so definitely
worth you know dueling up or you know
getting a squad together you so choose
to do so but you got a power slide
though
yes cyborg man it's it's getting wild
over here in fort night I hope he going
with with John Luke and eyes show idea I
really do hope that they add like a like
a custom game thing for this cuz with
with like the golf carts and stuff
there's a bunch of like dumb Conti games
you can do yeah it's not like like honor
system Halo to status zombie mode like
every 150 533 learn to math Eric I don't
think that will get like a straight-up
new map I think what they're doing is
they're taking their existing one and
just changing to keep it fresh and
exciting without having to create a
whole new area didn't make a pub go
fortnight crossover I don't know if that
would ever happen but it'd be
interesting to see would be hilarious to
go from suing
[Music]
sony will be sitting in the corner with
his arms crossed nope no fun so that's
it's exclusive exclusive y'all play save
the world uh I played save the world
back when it first came out a fair
amount James but not not too much these
days
Oh lightning bolt let's do that plan to
ban it's a hundred percent calculated
how can you become a good streamer I'll
let you know when I get there you can
give them the like normal tips though
like try to stream
you know regularly consistently yeah
find a schedule that Fitch's they stay
regular stream things that you like
exactly I don't don't follow trends
unless you like want to SEO the crap out
of her summer that's not just that those
like let's say fortnight is a thing
that's pretty big right but it's also
harder to get into because everyone else
is doing it too but like if you enjoy it
like you got to start with that right
like yeah and also don't don't get
discouraged if no one shows up
oh yeah it's like slow building you
gotta actually one of the best advice
was like you treat it more like it's a
hobby yeah and then as it grows then
like you're like cool like I could do
more with this but you just kind of do
it for fun to start with kind of get
your feet wet a little bit and then yeah
yeah don't don't like drop out of
college to be like ah I'm gonna start
being a streamer now yeah or don't quit
your job and say that you're gonna be a
streamer now just kind of kind of do it
on the side do it for fun and then also
don't forget that it's video games it's
it's meant to be a fun time you guys are
the best dreamers Oh
- nice that's very generous of you thank
you I appreciate it you're making you're
making my day I'm just glad that I get
to hang out with you guys while we play
some some video games but I'm gonna at
some point all right Tommy guns are cool
I like it I'm gonna do it we need SMG
damage heck yeah
hello MSD sports are you doing fortnight
or pub ha dad to you I think I feel like
there's room enough in my life for both
of them oh okay I can play both I feel
like I like pub go a little bit more
though feel like they got rid of all the
pop rocks and just put mushrooms there
instead yeah I'm good with this tiny I
need it they're just that way it's
probably people rotating play heavy rain
again really there's only so much David
cage we can we can we can down that the
catch but if we if we bring any dive
with Kai just games back
maybe Detroit if there's like a DLC or
something or or if we find a way to
convinced a to let us do it but I said
that's fine you just got to find a way
fine find a day where there's absolutely
nothing nothing else and and kind of
scope in on that we wanted though we
want we want to do some more silly day
with cage things
it wasn't get a top 10 here from just
doing nothing but running in a circle
I'm hoping to get one week he'll have a
good just do a stream where we go back
and do the beginning of Detroit again
and I just do the painting and piano
stuff again I still don't know how it
works that piano playing is very not
intuitive not like playing a piano and I
painted with all my heart that's all you
can ask for so I can't handle the
emotions I can't handle the polygons the
whole the whole stream during Detroit I
was I was trying not to cry
what gaming monitor are you guys using
this is not a that's great in here this
is just a pretty standard 1080p not even
high refresh rate or anything voluntary
but we use that that really popular TLC
in the speed zone though you're a TC l
or TC le that's like a good bang for
your buck 4k TV if you're talking about
like monitor though like I know we have
some Asus ones there alright do polygons
and emotions are the same thing crime we
live in the David cage world you can't
have emotions without polygons and the
more polygons you have the more emotion
up golf carts
always hang shot at ya know you tap the
touchpad when I'm bad at touching the
touchpad tapping the touchpad I'm bad at
touch padding the hell did not did so
we're doing shadows for sure I mean
you're right outside of tilted there's
got to be some some shooting going on
why do they run like the poop the pants
it for tonight maybe that's the the
secret that we all don't know yet season
six how do they all clean their pants by
the battle paths
get new newer cleaner pants do we just
go after him
just want to say hello hello Roman
Studios I hope you're having a good day
and thank you for for saying hello oh
this guy's gonna have to rotate out of
tilted at some point maybe we're just
gonna stay here yeah and die yeah oh the
cart guy died
it's unfortunate oh they're having
probably the best time of their life I
realize until I don't have a shotgun
that's fine you got this mg it's kind of
like a shotgun except not all at once
oh my god I'm getting shot from the of I
know oh oh hello he just tried to bolt
dang or Trice night me snipey snipey hey
Chaz how are you doing oh hello oh it's
a party killing it didn't deserve that
Bend I really didn't know dude you got
it you just you deserve all these things
you're doing you got it what it's there
we go
oh he sniped me probably like through
that window she's got really excited
about building do you think overwatch is
dead no no I don't think overwatch so
there's a different game we'll play a
different kind of game all right what
are we looking at floating or we gotta
go a snobby I think all right cool we're
gonna find some chests I'm profoundly
sad right now this might be the last
match guys just so you know alright
alright
rekt I tried Chaz I tried I didn't see
the sniper you're so bad that he got
confused I didn't want to say it crime
but it was kind of funny at least I
killed him yeah it's true well he say :
you could've been a lot worse he could
have actually I was like where is he I
was looking at where he built and I was
like oh how come he's not peeking I'm
like oh I got hit by shotgun
yes fancy just kind of cape man it's
awesome the the basketball there's one
like below shifty and there's like one
like what here so I could technically
try to knock two out we'd jump early I
like it maybe this time we won't run out
of materials tips for llama hunting I'm
not sure
Roman I just kind of got lucky I think
you just played the game I hope to find
one tip though is like you'll destroy it
faster than if you hold F though to open
it I just got a llama I did get a llama
I got lucky
real lucky I died the game before I got
my actual llama
I think there's a shield there nope it's
a tack shotgun
I got baited that's fine that's my I
think someone landed over there oh watch
TCL should you get the one that we got I
think is like the top one on Amazon I
think it's the s 6:05 or P 6:05 it's one
or the other
yeah what's it's a it's a solid like 4k
HDR TV for how much you got baby yeah
that's why I wanted the best TCL's are
the best bang for your buck but there
won't be like the top top of the line
but if you're just looking for something
good for the right price usually there's
good sales I would say wait for prime
day oh yeah I'm going up soon parties
kind of real soon see if you want to
figure out when there's gonna be a good
deal on that TV stuff I'm sure we'll
have some sort of stuff up for it for
you guys to kinda party you've got top
people on the case finding you the best
prime day deals jumpers fall in to traps
trap dance huh huh okay let's see put it
on the floor people come in there to
have a good time in you
he wanted the SMG damage more than I did
and he wanted it more than getting an
actual kill that's a heck of a thing
don't worry we'll sit up here in bandage
in the corner just like you would a
little up in the VIP yeah where's my
bottle service can't believe this
I ordered three Chuck jugs like seven
days ago yeah I thought he had SMG oh
there is take that we're really here for
the lightning bolt oh yeah which I don't
even know if I have enough you probably
have enough food yeah got some nail it
perfect a lot higher than you think
optical oh hello I need that the
building rules in for tonight are a real
show very real dummy they won't hit me
who really should rearrange all this
right so we can ditch the revolver
whatever is inside of your shoe we need
oh we need to go huh I mean if you feel
like it no we need to go there's the
next one like the arish oh it's kind of
up by the river again if you're heading
like straight north well I like how it's
got that little red carpet kind of thing
they're not red carpet but it's got the
stanchions yeah they really over there
it's it's by the bridge so it looks like
it's just north of the bridge a little
bit it's kind of like where you've got
it marked could always be watching now
Ben it's it's a dangerous world out here
42 people left 41 people left see the
tops we got six last time I hope I'm
paying attention to where we've placed
it we said it did taking everything
better if I didn't alright lightning
bolt where are you where you be a car on
that hill or that rock oh there's a
chest there just things just a real
weird formation there and alright it's
like a super chest
all right we're looking that is pretty
high up it's fine you got tons of
materials you're in the zone
everything's looking looking real good
hilarious really built the building
rules are just no there you go
maybe you can reach it through the floor
or not yes box it out so no one can get
to it it's a good a good plan how do I
know for Sam she's out of town all right
that was not the first plank
I was hitting for a wedding thing gosh
darn it can you still do double deagle I
don't know if they've changed that I
know that they change shotguns but all
right let's try this again except I'm
the lower on materials and I gotta get
all the way back up there just mildly
annoying
I needed to build one more game is
everything okay for tonight it's me it's
not the game it's me is everything okay
- no oh there's a chest there so you
wouldn't have known that that chest was
there if you if you didn't check it out
okay gee dad it hi I'm new to your
channel well hello dr welcome hope
you're having a good day if you don't
know this is game spots uh actual
YouTube channel hello you uploaded
videos all the time and we stream every
day if you do subscribe you'll be able
to be notified whenever we go live
Oh which is a good time that is correct
we do those things are factually correct
we do Daily News at 11 o'clock Pacific
so we get like a rundown of all the
biggest coolest news and then we we have
a little bit of a break we head right
into some some cool games cool games
cool games like fortnight on its fifth
season launch we get to hang out with
you guys correct
sub thank you
that keeps freaking me out but it's just
the circle closing I think yeah Chris
says congrats on your engagement hey oh
thank you
I appreciate it welcome as well Peyton I
saw you saying stuff earlier but I'm
glad that you're hanging out with us as
well cook to see you on many other
streams yeah see that this is the best
part when people come in and they're
like oh hey I'm new here what's going on
and you're like give them the stuff and
I'm like oh it sounds cool I'll come and
like stick around and then you end up
becoming friends with these people
because you see them in the streams all
the time really nice how far oh yeah
that's right rob handle it Robin the
chats telling you about the new show
happening today at 2 p.m. grave hoppers
catch it it's really cool in real wild
basically Rob and Mike are gonna hang
out and they're gonna play through a
list of games and as soon as they die in
one they're gonna have to move on to the
next
bump-bump and they play like at a harder
difficulty not like maybe not the
hardest but like at least one below the
hardest make sure it's challenging
because we don't want them to actually
play through the whole game we want them
to die so be sure to come back at 2 p.m.
Pacific for Robin Mike doing what they
do which will be in like an hour an hour
from now oh god you're right that's why
this is the last this is the last match
here hopefully we can end with a good
one got two lightning bolts so far we
got a kill I didn't use my SMG though I
didn't have one actually so when it
mattered DRS a question can you play
with other people on stream on a game
like fortnight so there's another one
right there
me and another person who's who's off on
vacation right now as well we're trying
to gear up for a show where we actually
focus more on playing with you guys
during livestreams fortnight apparently
doesn't let you play with other people
just yet what do you mean like you're
like a custom game thing oh yeah but you
would have to just like party up or
whatever yeah but we want to get like
want to get like a hundred people from
people in the chat coming in having a
good time but we want to build out more
more
kind of cool community hanging out
playing things kind of like how we did
with the Master Hunter when it came out
that kind of thing yeah I got your first
solo win on Wednesday welcome or
congratulations Peyton that that's
really I don't have a solo in what what
is it what is even a win all my wins and
fortnight are in 20 be 20 or 50 be 50
nothing wrong with that
the wins they're not 100% wins but hey
come in - it must be in California yeah
our offices in California I haven't
lived here for like 7 years now actually
but I'm originally from the Midwest
Michigan Michigan got the Great Lakes
right all five of them hanging out the
biggest amount of freshwater you can
find in one place I need more apples
apples are a thing they're like
mushrooms they're good for you seen your
red apples
you got it Payton sets it's kind of a
weird thing how people are like ah
witting bub goon fortnight's like super
easy to own Awad should do it all the
time these games are like
mathematically designed to have more
people lose than win it's it's a
remarkable thing when people win like
you'd be out a hundred other people
that's really badass sweet goat the
potato I hate this game that's cool
star-lord I mean Dodd all right I'm not
I'm not too big up on Pogo myself but
it's it's kind of fun every now and then
with friends
I mean I'd much rather be playing like
yeah cos or something but here I am
I'm in Toronto
oh nice Tina is a pretty cool place only
been a couple of times to bet it's gonna
be on PC or ps4 Mon Xbox maybe we can
try to mix it up every now and then
monster hunter might be more of an ask
for that but we're surprised the angle
oh I'm gonna do it for the lightning
bolt don't give a [ __ ]
heck yeah Oh golf there's our golf cart
to make your escape - Oh grab that golf
cart and drift on out of here
dude I believe in this this is this is
the run hello that's the side seat
driver skirt get on out of here
there's girls see you later thank you
DeAndre first subscribing as well I kind
of power slide that was a pleasure
enjoying yourself and you you find us
enjoyable
mr. Skaar we missed a scar
dude scars pretty big but not as big as
big as these drifts loss sick intestine
it's like nice for the initial boost but
it actually doesn't feel like it does
that much I really don't think you get
that much of a speed boost it's more of
like three six tone and a little boost
off oh there's a car sir there's a car
that or there's a person building I
can't believe this
this is a wild time top ten top ten
power slide I don't know if if we can we
can friend you just yet but like I said
that the show where John Luke and I are
gonna be doing things we're probably
gonna have to add people as friends
anyway uh it stick around and we'll have
have accounts for you to add
later on oh why the demigod that the
headshot arm though you placed eight I
only got my one chance to shoot I should
have built I was having too much fun
power sliding oh well we got like four
lightnings there though now he has my
two med kits I've whatever it's it's
fine it's fine
you got a sweet 360 off of it or night
Tokyo Drift hell yeah I want to be the
DK I was not though I was not Donkey
Kong the damn King no how dare you how
dare you alright thank you guys all for
tuning in to the weekly challenges
thanks Ben for hanging out obviously
yeah anytime yeah it was a fun time I
think that the karts gonna bring some
people like to do oh or a quad up Eric
dye your hair blonde and you'll become
that character yeah I I jokingly like
was like oh yeah I could totally do my
hair like that guy and then I was like
mice not blonde and I I am very much
past the stage in my life where I think
I'll do that I haven't done that I
haven't bleached my hair or had tips or
anything like that since high school
back when I thought it was cool and you
know like all the bad boy bands and
stuff like that we're doing it you ever
did you ever do the frosted tips that I
did frosted awesome yeah because it
wasn't very hard you can no I bleach
really easily and you just like take
like a latex glove and you just kind of
like dab every anywhere you wanted to
really but we appreciate it
check out gamespot.com if you guys are
having trouble with any of the guides we
do guides weekly we streamed this for
tonight challenges weekly as well where
we do our best
yeah our best to you know complete the
challenges hang out with you guys try
out some of the new stuff but yeah it's
a fun time
don't miss grey pop sleep coming up in
less than an hour at 2 p.m. Pacific yep
Robin Mike coming through doing some
real intense hardcore gaming for you
guys to enjoy new show don't miss it
otherwise you'll be a fool if you miss
it don't be a fool and yeah stay in
school stay in school or your full team
keep it cool more rhymes all the times
close the show thanks guys appreciate it
yeah he showed up we had a fun time
the golf cart action it's a good old
girl time yep well send us out of here
yeah your goodness out of here
all right press the self-destruct button
goodbye everybody
you